si los abogados
que además fue ex jefe de campaña de
Donald Trump Pues están argumentando que
el hecho de no haber
cooperado con la justicia va de la mano
con los privilegios presidenciales que
argumentan tiene por haber precisamente
hecho parte de la administración de
Donald Trump privilegios presidenciales
que Donald Trump ha apelado a ellos
precisamente para no solamente demorar
en la investigación de que Investiga lo
que ocurrió el 6 de enero en La Toma del
Capitolio sino también pues para
proteger a sus asesores cercanos entre
ellos estivaron así que los abogados
dicen que va en contradicción la
cooperación de Steve varón con la
justicia y los privilegios
presidenciales que argumentativaron
tiene por haber hecho parte del grupo
cercano del ex presidente usted lo decía
bien inicialmente se le acusaba al
departamento de Justicia lo acusaba y
quería que van a pagar a seis meses de
cárcel y una multa de 200 millones de
dólares sin embargo pues la sentencia es
mucho menor y balón no tendrá que ir a
prisión mientras que se define
precisamente todo este tema de la
apelación muchos analistas acá en
Washington dicen que precisamente esta
apelación es para demorar este proceso
Más allá de las elecciones de medio
término de elecciones al congreso porque
se espera que los republicanos vuelvan a
tomar control de la cámara de
representantes a tomar al tomar control
de El legislativo la presión judicial la
presión legislativa a los allegados al
círculo cercano de Donald Trump va a ser
diferente Y entonces la defensa pues
mucho más tranquila y mucho más amplia
por parte de los cercanos a Donald Trump
pero hay que Resaltar también que Steven
no tiene solamente este juicio pendiente
este juicio por no colaborar con la
justicia sino que también en Nueva York
tiene otro juicio que es por defraudar a
los donantes simpatizantes de Donald
Trump al pedirle dinero para construir
el muro pero a ver usado ese dinero
precisamente para otros fines se
acumulan los problemas Steve vanon que
reacciones conocemos hasta esta hora en
Washington Cristóbal
Sí a la salida de la corte
estuvo hablando con los medios de
comunicación reaccionando a la salida
también de la corte lo esperaban mucha
gente que le gritaba mentiroso y le
gritaba traidor a la patria sin embargo
Esteban pues repartió varias varios no
insultos pero si estuvo bastante fuerte
en contra por ejemplo de Nancy pelosi en
contra de El fiscal merrick Garden a
quienes les dijo que precisamente el 8
de noviembre cuando posiblemente según
lo indica las encuestas los republicanos
vuelven a tomar control de la cámara de
representantes ahí en ese momento pues
van a recibir fuego cruzado porque al
tener esa mayoría de en el legislativo
pues va no van a tener esta este juego
político que algunos dicen tiene los
demócratas para seguir acusando y seguir
enredando al círculo cercano de Donald
Trump muchos republicanos entre ellos
Marjorie Taylor Green la congresista que
es bastante radical pues
y entonces pues este juicio polariza aún
más este ambiente político acá en
Washington entre demócratas y
republicanos